[Music]
[Applause]
ben ali
always collecting fake things
my dear friends if we want peace
we must be convinced of our
actions and our commitments through
date
[Music]
[  Applause]
mr president my guts ladies
and gentlemen heads of state and
government ladies and gentlemen my
dear friends i am honored and
deeply moved to be with you at
the peace forum in this week of
commemoration this year we mark
30  years since the fall of the berlin wall
and the opening of the iron curtain
thirty years since the victory of
the solidarity movement in warsaw or the
velvet revolution in prague
thirty years since the human chain
of independence from vilnius to riga
and tallinn  and of course we mark
this week the end of the
fratricidal fights of the first
world
war this war this human tragedy
imposes on all of us the obligation never to
forget  bind never to forget
the worst that humanity can produce in order to be
able to build together a
better future future it is this duty of
memory and action that brings us together
today but I would also like to talk
about another anniversary
c  it was 170 years ago here in paris that
victor victor hugo opened
the peace congress that day he speaks of a europe
of peace and i quote the continent
instead of being a battlefield would be
a workshop where  we would have before our eyes
the hope the joy and the effort of all
towards the common well-being
end of quote willis a gentleman and
structures many lives all match
high price victor hugo the world to be prow
of the raï which appears this mysterious today  we
think that this book of yes s'il use
peas font un god nights this line to the
internationals of france
interbrand single market to the rule of
law
we shall never get off to we have come
and the wire not suicide is not
obvious to  because not only
dualpensports du t  chad accosted if his
atmosphere
lyrics on because we expect every
member damage junior all this debate
all look to tommy from iron man
stand-up standard common cause
particular mines force india today was you can
to hot diop contribute to tackle
challenger justin and  matthew
climatechange digitization demography
mike richards cops
yes if there is no ago in the
new goes through the new york times
yes but jean désy force of words
landry sponso life as a leader
we have to contribute geopolitics to the
commissions highland games of  how to
world locking popping unit eiu which
collects and you the various
ramdane parks like nintendo world my virgin
and to regions yes yes like that of a
square divided by the wrist guard in
tonight by 400 m hurdles you drop
building responsibility for my  soul from
my friends and from our party and yes
however the near everything to the planet
good governance fight against corruption
respect lightning or flora respect  it
must be said that the tube people before
anyway the police told us thomas
clubs like valence fit for defense in
choi s president of the act of the
european commission go one man show
battler opinionway walle quick to
beat pretty geopolitics india dreams and
have  fun fun to try to safety at
appendix crowds de facto death
anne moss chic no wa 12 and z3 family to
be free to form cameron and 20 youth on
list of what you see is it to have found
what you see is it to  do you want to
finish then grids irony of the
spurs
we need you had the state and government
joss internacional
regional organizations the organization company
journalists activists you're a rich or
die in a way to peace
ladies and gentleman inoni beats and 7
p.m. it  is to go broke the world's
women and men lost to gaza freedom
simply for better life standing together
des beatles hey you my joy of course du
challenge sweetface studio different from
need for speed from enemies all st  one
together is stronger than ever à la
swell non à fasken faceà pts de 10.13
glaude challenger on it together do we
have the strain everything is part
snack in any case of can't we fight
climate change and invest in progress
can we stand  for peace and prosperity
france
[applause]
chishan chinese vice president wang
qishan vice president of the people's republic
of china will now speak
[applause
] first
is people so that they become
too believe dear i fall to l  water
him and others still have no other
everyone believes it manual idea I
sing again on youtube women this if
there is not a title
it is a comedy signed by the
co-pilots at rocky kong country  too what to
say
thierry deve next in your ass rue
galt weary kind we say chick
yes if china cheng obliged if this
area are kir foot south indie rush
happy when i say i go calmly
south to the leaf objects contain who
gon jinn des  vs  haudeires for one of the
fishermen from the lucky islands i told him
as much dropped 0.20 from wendy taiwan
china congo thomas case it didn't tick me off
on the outcome of a sheet
lortie nests of tchaoudjo chinese layer that
will fall  no clues will find
hemingway holds leftists we are young
there is it's an exchange a hero it's a
show flip-flops in diapers china ya nipples
milk quotas contaminates them everything it's
now all the same here at 300
euros per peasant family  y intends to
stick to the dalits by tonya lie to
thanked me minto trulli
I like myself pierrât croco chemy chabosseau
y also ionians otherwise what to bring back this
sky will fall el quaida mention minto
sushi active sites at
page kangxi vos de chine dong hwa lee
chong chin congo all  molmy heads are falling let's
increase our lines whose jean
only holds fender one chiang pin kung
photo laure sudre his claude
lebanese champion in flip-flops origins time 80
like a brother in mein kampf and in six
sites to mach beings  ine to tube man x
draconian gold cracks in our had to
digest that of the right to wait
if they sold their blood pythons
boas m
this will give tutorials [ __ ] my tho
low blows thierry bouillet shragaï core quad
between eva joly in orléans delay in
the purchase on the title against
sochaux too much time but tienne may choco
american released a good match like maïga
saïda support only holds cargo like
micheline sentence released in béarn
tongo goiania dead the myth he never a
year eiffage does not if he  will therefore remain
unchanged too eager to play it in favor
with us the subjects bailly must overcome
too binh chanh it will be necessary to go to
brignais our pin kung
I love pin too much
for me jean trading congress trails
coaching highco expensive in nice
around  air if they scoop chairlift singer
at the end of the trail chopard
often live tommissen world pioneer
undermine that name da rocha gas and
china horses for maintenance simbi xinchun
qishan shoes he changes libyan ali
triki would change 1200 in kuwait apart from
where to
go singer country tshiala
first matches including the end jcat
when watching too much football if the adq in the west indies
than as subjects they
drew from it charles giga man jon thiel here
does not contain  for the microphone dated Saturday
at very heavy of the ump
family want this revenge to fight
today from giteau poudrier modric
here revitalize sky will fall minto and
daf factory tenderly taxes these women
as long as there was diego del igm inc
iguodala place  this enchanting site from
him in the
tanguy project will also go well
for m like itunes shopping wade
chaoui but without saying ms. bachelot for
the trail 100 you also have to find
August 12 at rock in my who is starting his twingo
sees the multitouch in three stages
I am  went to work but cindy
right knee i'm not too late yet
and studied it choi for our etienne this
product combines da santa fe product
contains we have there here like gap
old cream eng  ine of fiji tonga this south
it lives again does not hold on three quarters
suits like coty at south
why road would
fall from general intro appeals to
all men women and holes of the nine out of
ten the sellers went to vibrate in
combat leadership fall authier this
cylinder of  tachira to get into your
in this construction site
those of chinese shoes ding
with areva
flip-flops above while a piece of a
road
basket july fell at her house without
role of steward vandal to the maximum there is a
hand on it
sooner or later  designate themselves by hearing by
intoning his eyeshadow big
boss makes there is a big one of the jo of the
almond trees this guy and the noise combo that
changes
congoone siro pro3 will win in vg
at maier badly and in the senate too nice
young by others otherwise  boss diamond
fall to the coach of the sky according to bcg country
sanchez a kitten time drink i will do
the course the more he would condition
and forget that she was going apologetic
holds next thursday tropea h against  we
go die on pole we signed town hall of
chemillé tango well sure we sing
indian aware of adventure line quan
hearing sows in progress between girlfriends
camille reeds kunda if I believe tiguan
yes he quibbles origins on one side j toda
contains  as a deacon are here a
part we create avenge south and ten
against eleven of them draw
opera wade return falls trudon
obviously you're talking on a notch that's
what sonia protic lofo
maintaining a quarter and in yen champagne and everything
go and we whisper 13 stops
spinal sindo coja fight fadhal du pole
cabin cynicism nor king i read ultra the
most intimate family in trento barter in the
eyes medicine of charlton mr sunshine
are too bad photos of old
times welcomed by aurélie min and
where  he handled ue china keeps dogs
former party min china to believe himself
sindo for all a good idea to
write there for murray more than we have and
approach households us troussi
city series would have ammunition cause  the
town and south we thank virginia
london genre vincenzo iv where to find a
noise thiam cros dimebag at hitiaa
jacqueline driss and on a robin
capital cruise and in 2003 if the copy is not
in step to change that for me and I have ar
put it back  the hand when we oblige to your
media
i will get hig had a dispute in pro b
r
i had to go ping call whose fine
waste will then not play the
man chu dialogue of the tribute to my dog
and besides
[applause  ]
but what felix tshisekedi president
felix tshisekedi president of the
democratic republic of congo will
now speak
and
mr emmanuel macron president of the
french republic
ladies and gentlemen heads of state
and government but on the president
of the paris forum for  peace, ladies
and gentlemen, Mr. President, the
French Republic,
thank you for having associated me with
this laudable initiative which will
help us to seize the opportunity
to discuss the  he ways and means
of establishing a lasting peace in the world
we are today faced
with one of the greatest challenges of another
time, that of winning peace,
preserving it and transmitting it to
future generations in order to win this
peace every man every state must
question its contribution to
providing solutions to the challenges that
threaten humanity our
common heritage because peace is not
only the silence of arms but
it is also the provision of answers to
problems related to youth
famine climate change and
health problems such as virus epidemics
to preserve peace we must
share with others
engage in a debate on the solutions
mentioned by each other
so it is possible to  having a
common agenda one of the major a certain number
of cross-cutting values ​​and
giving people and the planet the primacy of
our efforts we are indeed
faced with a major challenge that cannot be
suffocated  laugh at any
negligence any red herrings and I would
add any superficial solutions
wars conflicts terrorism
in the world and security must
stop we just have to want it together
and we will get there
because it is our responsibility
common and history will judge us
I know in fact to propose a
real world coalition for the
restoration of peace while complaining
necessary for the development of the
world
ladies and gentlemen there is no need
to remind this august assembly
no continent is  spared
by insecurity
you will agree with me that i will not go back
in five minutes
to the case of each continent
that is why i would like to focus
on africa and the
democratic republic of congo
my country today africa plus  that
all the other continents are shaken
by conflicts of wars and by
terrorism less than 10 years ago
west africa knew peace
and expanded  has endowed through ecowas
with a security tool for deterrence
and prevention of any conflict
today unfortunately we
deplore the terrorism of
boko haram April from the east is
not spared the terrorists either  shebab
is death and desolation
central africa is also experiencing
conflicts in chad in the central africa and in
southern sudan the democratic republic of
congo
located at the crossroads of several
sub-regional communities can be
considered as the country which has paid
the price  the strongest price the efforts have been made
for the pacification of the country is
today only five provinces
thanks to the forces of the army of the
armed forces of the democratic republic of the
congo and the collaboration of the
monusco remains still struck by
the  insecurity while being convinced of
the effectiveness of the military solution,
I think that we should also develop
a whole program to raise awareness among the
populations and dialogue between the
different  ferent communities
the military solution is essential to
fight the armed groups certainly but
in addition to that it is necessary to answer the
problems of the youth who need
more supervision more democracy
and employment africa in general
with its position  geostrategic its
young population and its
natural resources must cease to be a
problem for the world but rather
become an important link in the
solution to the problems of the world
ladies and gentlemen to come to the case
of my country I would like here to salute the
bravery of our people  who suffered in
his flesh and on his soil a
condensed horror due to the absence of peace
but despite this his strength of resilience
and his attachment to the values ​​of
peace remained intact
that is why we hired him  in
a fierce struggle against anti-
values ​​the democratic republic
of the congo
today destabilized in its eastern part
will very quickly become an
important part of solutions to the challenges
the world is
currently facing in fact the congo basin
and its great forest massif will
contribute to the fight against
global warming a
theme dear to my esteemed colleague
counterpart emmanuel macron here present
these arable lands well exploited can
reason b twice the
food deficit  world these fresh waters
representing 53% in africa and 13% in
the world are potentially and deserves
its potential energy forgiveness evaluated
at 100 thousand megawatts of which 44 miles
for the only son of in to its soil very
rich in strategic minerals are as
many  assets to contribute to
peace and stability in the world,
ladies and gentlemen,
I can reassure you that the
democratic republic of the congo will respond.
thank you gentlemen emmanuel
macron close preceded by factory we have a
blurry text sir emmanuel  macron
President of the French Republic not
now to take the floor
[Applause]
thank you very much,
ladies and gentlemen, heads of state of
government,
ladies and gentlemen, leaders
of
international organizations, regional organizations,
ladies and gentlemen, vice presidents,
vice prime minister,
leaders of organizations  non-
governmental
corporate foundations elected here present and and
I probably forget thank you for being
born there for this second edition
of the paris forum for peace so this
is perhaps the hardest edition
I  the said that the ecc tively
because the first edition there was a
lot of people since it was the
centenary of the armistice so we
had managed to catch
more than 60 heads of state of government
and there were if I may  say the
charms of the unknown the second edition
is basically starting to become a
stable appointment and there may be
the risks of habit and d  So your
presence here, your commitment just as
much as you are, is a
reality check for us. It's proof that
it's taking, but that
we also need to build something that's
sustainable, that is to say useful and  so I
really wanted to thank you for
your presence, your mobilization
but also to say how much I am
convinced that this forum of paris for
peace is what we are
doing collectively to a very deep utility
I would say that the first of its
utilities c  is what we
just heard from having an
indian activist then the elected president of the
european commission the chinese vice president
the president of the
democratic republic of congo there are
few places where this data with the same
force and  where this sequence can
take on as much meaning and it is
illustrative of this approach, that is to
say of those by whom what our
world today is made of and what
makes it possible to undo if we do not
don't put all these energies
around the table on a common project a
common agenda
then you said it the lady the
president yesterday without a year we celebrated
peace at the end of the first
world war not only in france in
all the  europe
many here had their country sometimes
physio it is descended from this war the
whole world was concerned
and europe
think about that time never again there
is a lesson to be learned among
many others who are happy with this
period is that we failed to
build lasting peace because
we failed to emerge from this first
world conflict found the right
ways of multilateral cooperation
it was the first attempt at the society of nations
and we did not succeed
then  that no one
reasonably thought that less than 20 years
later new
forms of brutality would begin than 20 years later
an even more terrible war new
world war was going to  again tore apart
europe and the world and thirty
years ago almost to the day
you said it the berlin wall fell and with
it divisions of europe sometimes
betrayals resentments and we
all thought then that it is  formidable
freedom fighter not only
in germany but everywhere in
eastern europe who had sometimes prepared this
moment had drawn a kind of
unstoppable force we were going to experience a
new teleology of our
international system everywhere democracy
was going to spread everywhere happiness
go  kiss us and basically
everywhere peace some talk about the end
of history was going to be revealed and there too
we missed his predictions
this time unfortunately also
since if there has been a happy time in
our European continent which has followed the
last few years  showed us
how new tearings of new
contemporary fractures could put an
end to what was then perceived as  me an
unstoppable perspective I take these
two examples and these two anniversaries
because we are almost
in line with his legacies to
say that there is no evidence in the
matter we are talking about and even if
contemporary times  may seem
difficult
it is sometimes in difficult times that
we build useful solutions and
I took two happy moments to
say that the predictions of then were
then thwarted by our own
weaknesses, our paralysis or our own
errors there  therefore has a lot to look forward
to when we meet again because
it is obscured by deep fractures
and by a lot of pessimism
and so that is why I believe very
deeply in this forum of paris have been
caught up in what we are living and the
three interventions which opened our
forum have shown this, I believe, an
unprecedented crisis of our international system,
unprecedented because
it does not come for the first  e
time at the end of a world war but
that it is linked
I will say it to profoundly
new challenges and an endogenous crisis of our
system
the two together are a reunion in
a way a unique chemical reaction
let me explain  we have a crisis in
our global political and economic
system this system which basically the
social
market economy openness free trade
cooperation systems thinking after the
second world war was
tremendously effective for 70 years
it released hundreds  of millions of
people of poverty,
you have reminded us of this, particularly in
your country, Mr. Vice President, it
has made it possible to pacify an enormous
region, thought that war or
conflict was unstoppable,
it has made possible an unprecedented balance control system,
but  recent
years have shown this it has caused
new inequalities to re-emerge sometimes in
our societies it has fractured contemporary societies
giving rise to  e also a
crisis of our democracies with a doubt
in all the Western democracies
which was the pillar it made
unilateralism reappear sometimes even
at those which were the guarantors in
last resort of this
international system and thus we have if I
can say  an endogenous crisis of the system
which is that on the political economic level
this system is today in crisis is
jostled and at the same time
problems have emerged for
ten years that are profoundly new, in any
case with this force
the demographic problem and a
only one of its consequences which is the
phenomenon of the great migrations from which
we live and we sometimes only deal
with the consequences but which is
much broader much
deeper how to feed a planet
which continues to grow how to manage the
demographic imbalances of which I
remind you of  elsewhere the main
migratory forces are played out
within africa itself sometimes  within the
Asian continent also with
major disruptions
the technological and digital challenge and
all that prevail 2 transformations
of work but also of our imaginations
of the interrelationships of our countries and the
climate challenge mainly the fight
against global warming and  the fight
for biodiversity
these three great challenges I am
probably not exhaustive
but these three great challenges have added to the
challenge which is not new to it but which
continues to be a fight for the fight
for freedoms and the demo of
democracy  There is therefore a moment of
fracture in the international system and in
our own societies, when to
meet this challenge we need
more cooperation and therefore the risk that
we collectively face is that the
temptation will re-emerge in our countries for
all those who  expressed themselves all those
who are present either in the depths of
laziness the first risk is to say to themselves we have
organizations we like them
not the questions have  no they have
sometimes lost their purpose
no one understands anymore and let's raise but
hide this breast that we cannot see
as they say in Molière and it
will go better I don't think so at all
I have shown them sometimes in their
time maybe  some in this room
a few days or a few
weeks ago I think we need the
truth prudishness or hypocrisy it does
n't work these days
why because our fellow citizens
see it we are in an open world
the experts who are present here the
citizens the activists see the
consequences of this world there when it no
longer works they tell us
so hypocrisy and silence are not
a solution and intellectual laziness
or action n  is
not a
second option either, at least as risky as
it is non-cooperation,
that is to say the return
to unilateralism or to a form of 10
pairs of regionalism, I believe that this
option is also very  ès risky
they tend some what we can
say it is much more effective to fall
back to respond either even to the own
challenge of bringing a
closure solution because the evil in a
way would be linked to a world that has become too
open I  don't believe it either we have
tested this option in the past it
produces war nationalism it
's war
when they forget you reminded them
distinguish themselves auxerre trisha thank you for that
the difference between
nationalism and patriotism  and the non-
cooperation of
deconstructing is in a way that
we have at least succeeded in building
during these last decades and it
can lead to a third risk which
would be a possible path to
hegemony at the bottom we could say
to ourselves in the face of these crises we must  'there are
new powers emerging, we're
going to get behind them, it would be a
solution to say there are a few
great powers, they're going to settle the
matter for others  res and we accept in
a way to get behind I
believe that hegemony and I say it from a
country which sometimes tried this path
for others it was the colonial moment
of the French republic we
held this speech  or if they include it in the
name of freedom by saying we are going to
solve the world's problems for
you we are enlightened we are going to enlighten
others it will work better it lasts a
while it does not work very long
it is no longer possible  in
today's world and therefore the path of hegemony
or distribution among a few
hegemonic powers is also
not desirable because it
will again produce resentment
again frustration again from the d2
the Geneva humiliation for  to respond to
these challenges that one of the most
difficult and most complex paths is
that of balanced cooperation
that which is called multilateralism,
that is to say that they accept
discussions, disagreements,
mediations to find solutions
common solutions and for me the
dialogue which took place between the first three
speeches that we had and which will
take place for two days between the
different continents the different
actors is in this respect deeply
essential Europe first of all is a
continent where  the solution must be
built,
madam president, thank you
for being there in a busy agenda and
for having strongly supported this vision
of a geopolitical europe as
you have I indeed believe very
deeply that europe has a  part of the
answer to the solution for a simple reason
our europe we are several here to
participate actively and that good evening
members of the european union then
geographical sense of this europe
we all have this role europe is a
laboratory of multilateralism
perhaps  to be moreover the
most complex laboratory because it has been
exhausted for millennia in
civil wars
so europe is undoubtedly the place
in the world where we know the best  ow the price
of cooperation or rather the price of
non-cooperation and therefore the treasure which
is the ability to build balances
including when or would push
this geopolitical Europe to the difference
it must be sovereign democratic
but in fact build the solutions
of new  balances and I think to be
this kind of two-thirds of confidence
between the united states of america and
china if you allow me,
sir vice president, which supposes that it
and its voice of independence are its own
and that they help  to build
useful solutions, as you
reminded us, as you committed yourself to for a
moment, Madam President, and I
think it is tremendously useful that we
continue to be its partners in
international forums and
actors in the construction of these solutions
news in a Europe thus rethought
with all our regional partners and
I think that Europe has this vocation
of aggregating around itself the  powers
of goodwill and in this respect
the initiative for an alliance for
multilateralism pushed by the
ministers of foreign affairs here
present and I thank them for it
is an initiative which was started on the
sidelines of the united nations summit which
will be continued by  the ministers mass
the drian with their colleagues and which is
I think a very important initiative
which is emblematic of what precisely
this europe can bring in the
concert of nations alongside the
european commission then there is the
zee you said it sir  the vice
president many heads of state and
government are also there who come
from central asia or india or other
asian countries to today formidable
challenges of stability of peace of
construction there also of solutions
clarification news sometimes of
border conflict
demographic and religious challenges it is a
laboratory
it has often been in recent
years a laboratory of  conflicts which
then have always affected Europe
and Asia and in this 8th nursery rhyme
with our own challenges I repeat it
here with great force and to say
all the commitment which is ours in
some of the conflicts which
still divide it but the  asia you said is
now stabilizing
the initiatives you have taken
is part
of the european union's connectivity initiatives is
a useful complement and a voice of this
dialogue also with china and  the
role of china, as you have
recalled, is an important element of
this stabilization and I thank you,
vice president, for having had
very strong words in this regard, I believe
that the role in particular on the
climate challenge that you will have  brought
is what you have started to decline
is very important and in terms of the
fight against global warming
as in the fight for
biodiversity the path the role
that asia will be able to build and  st an
extremely structuring element 2020 in this
respect includes several meetings
that of a Sino-European dialogue where the
fight against global warming
as the economic subject will be decisive
that also of the cop15 biodiversity which
will be held in China is an
essential meeting  for the international order
and then there is africa dear president
if these credits which you spoke
admirably by a not only of
your country but of the conflicts many
presidents are here present and have
also taken on their time even though
they  are courageously at the head of
countries that are being jostled by
terrorism and by groups that
challenge national sovereignty that
threaten not only the stability of
their country of an entire continent but
also ours and here too we have a
linked destiny and I believe that  Africa,
as I recalled last night with
some of you, is
today living with our
collectively a challenge and  t has long
been an object of multilateralism
it is becoming one of the
subjects of multilateralism, that is to say
that it plays an active part in it and I
want to salute the commitment
of the African states here present and more
broadly of the countries of  africa who are
taking their destiny into their own hands are
building concrete solutions
tunisia knew how to do this with
great courage when it came to
rebuilding democracy several years ago
i know if the presence of the prime
minister who with great force
alongside the late president and his
boyfriends to lead the destinies of the country
after this democratic miracle, but the whole
African continent and I am thinking in
particular of the Sahel today has this
challenge and the strength of African countries to
take up political and military challenges
and security is essential
and we have in this new
international order to also build
new solutions within the framework of the
united nations allowing to accompany  er
better than we do today
this security capacity of africa
but also help it to build in terms
of education, health,
environment and economy
those which are the four solutions which
allow  to build lasting peace and
to prevent
the destabilizing factors from appearing in the universities in this
triptych and I obviously do not forget
and I will come back to this in a moment the
other regions that I have mentioned less
but in this  dialogue that you have
started with us and there is the beginning
of a solution of a common agenda of
new partnerships that we can
forge and I believe that in our
ability to build contemporary solutions
there is obviously
dialogue with the states  States of America
and the American countries,
no, I hope that in the third
edition we will succeed in mobilizing
the latter more to contribute
even more to this dialogue, but there is the
capacity to build ways and
means of cooperation  ion news we
have speakers they are sometimes
blocked the united nations is
part of it it is our responsibility to
continue to move forward to better share
a common agenda
and therefore for me I will conclude on this
point the value-added force of this
forum of our  work of the ongoing repair
is to know how to rebuild new forums,
new ways of cooperation, a
new alliance between our
international organizations as
we were able to do in the fight against
inequalities a few weeks ago in biarritz
between international organizations
and the different countries between the
governments the
international organizations the ngos foundations
academic actors and businesses and
basically through these two-day exchanges
but through the work throughout
the year that we have a
shared agenda that of the fight against
discrimination and access to the law
that precisely the construction of
new balances and  t new
digital rights that of
the fight against global
warming and for biodiversity
that of a sustainable structure to
deal with migratory issues that also
of the fight against geographical imbalances
and the resolution of
conflicts
many are affected here and  I hope
that, apart from our discussions, we
will be able to help advance several
sensitive subjects,
that is our common agenda if it is
shared by all the actors here
present have already done useful work
and then it is the construction
new forms of cooperation
alliances before i jy for example supported
by our companies to fight
against inequalities the partnership
for information and democracy supported by
reporters without borders is supported
by several elected governments
companies to fight against
misinformation and for a  better
cooperation the christchurch call
between business governments
to fight against terrorist content
and make it possible to act more
effectively here are some examples
of concrete innovations where players
who did not speak to each other until then
decide to act together
this forum will be full of
new initiatives we must continue to launch
them  somehow not to
compete with the forums of
contemporary multilateralism but to
help reinvent them to complete them and
above all to act usefully
why unilateralism is rising in some
countries why doubt is re-emerging because
what our citizens reproach us for
is sometimes our inefficiency
other  desire not to see or to act
insufficiently quickly and I believe
that the construction of these
useful solutions of its new alliances of its
innovations is an extremely
important element of the collective response to our
contemporary challenges in our countries is
a way of combining this
cooperation that I was explaining a
moment ago I will conclude th  n quoting the
late agnes et l'air is a
wonderful activist like you trisha
de la liberté she was over 90
she was a hungarian intellectual
and every day she went swimming
in the great lakes of hungary and in the
month of july n'  didn't come back from one
of these swims because the spirit of
revolt and indignation preserves for a
long time and continues to give
courage and agnes et l'eire who was a
wonderful woman with this sentence
saying that our time needs more
that others of a form of heroism
who give themselves the task of grasping what
the present is the task remains say
they make themselves available to what
is to us comes this availability to those who
help us well and this heroism  about which
agnès et l'air speaks is this ability to
understand the world as it comes to
us to think about it and try to provide
useful answers neither the cowardice of
not seeing to remain in our habits nor
the cowardice of  do not do  the comfort
of being far from everyday life our fellow citizens
what we are talking about here these two wars
of conflicts of imbalance is
everyday life our fellow citizens it is up
to us to settle it we have received a
mandate for that it is up
to us to continue to act usefully and that
is why I believe very
deeply in the usefulness of this forum of
paris for peace and that I thank the
president and the director
general all the organizers but
also all the contributors
and that I thank you very
deeply for  your presence
today in paris thank you to you
[Applause]
ladies and john
[Music]
motive takes on May 6th kind facebook
how is the team then by senegal
in bayoud lime  -of-funds